[Music]
morning Donnie everything okay
no not really my kid needs braces on her
teeth my car needs a transmission job my
wife wants me to take her to Florida but
I'm behind on the mortgage payments my
uncle called from India and he needs
money for my niece's wedding and I got
this strange rash on my back how about
you I'm okay very droll Patterson yeah
when you're a child you learn there are
three dimensions height width and depth
like a shoebox then later you hear
there's a fourth dimension time get
poetry is really good and someday you
might let the world read it I mean me
right you are a great poet oh that's
english bulldogge right don't like daddy
dog Jack my G or give me something to
look forward to that I guess you drive
the bus write your name really Patterson
my real name is Patterson well that's
kind of crazy right working on a poem
for you I love fun yeah I guess if it's
for you it's a love poem I had a tree
yeah trees all your poems are still in
that one notebook your secret notebook I
go through trillions of molecules that
move aside to make way for many poem
both sides trillions more stay where
they are
Patterson bus 23 I have a situation damn
thing could have exploded to a Powerball
I could be realizing my dream to be a
country singer national you're right
calm down Nashville human-sized that's
not likely without love what reason is
there for anything he's not gonna do
anything crazy
posture by Ian Patterson
how what he's very poetic if I asked it
to be
replan myself
[Music]